[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con este 9 de
abril se ha establecido como día
nacional de la memoria y solidaridad con
las víctimas en colombia de conflicto
armado justamente este viernes en
médicos del mundo francia colombia el
doctorado en salud pública de la
universidad nacional y la red salud paz
presentan a la comisión de la verdad de
este país un informe sobre los impactos
en la salud y la población víctima del
conflicto entre los territorios
colombianos nos acompaña a nicolás dota
coordinador general de médicos del mundo
gracias por estar con nosotros el señor
don está cuáles han sido los principales
impactos del conflicto armado en la
salud de las poblaciones de los
territorios en los que ustedes han hecho
presencia
buenos días raúl muchas gracias por el
espacio primero que nada decir que la
violencia se dio en estos territorios en
el marco de una violencia estructural en
todos los casos descritos el abandono
estatal y la marginación histórica de
las comunidades se enmarcan las
problemáticas en salud relacionadas con
el conflicto luego ya hay una violencia
directa que comúnmente se describe en
asesinatos desapariciones masacres de
desplazamiento forzado violencia sexual
amenazas torturas confinamientos y luego
hay unos desenlaces en salud
concretamente las afectaciones sobre los
efectos que hemos descrito como más
prevalentes como consecuencia del
conflicto se dan en la salud mental en
afectaciones psicológicas en la
malnutrición y desnutrición crónica en
estos territorios en afectaciones en la
salud sexual y reproductiva muchos casos
relacionadas con la violencia sexual
y en las enfermedades transmitidas por
vectores ya que el conflicto e
imposibilitó el control de enfermedades
como la leishmaniasis y la malaria que
son entregas en estos territorios ahora
cuál es la relación entre el derecho a
la salud y el conflicto en comunidades
históricas abandonadas por el estado
bueno para hablar del derecho a la salud
hay que referenciar la observación
general 14 del consejo económico social
de las naciones unidas
la observación general 14 nos habla de
que los estados tienen la obligación de
proteger
de proteger y implementar las medidas
necesarias para garantizar el derecho a
la salud en cualquier situación quiere
decir esto que el accionar de terceros
de grupos armados
o inclusive una situación de conflicto
como reconoce el derecho internacional
humanitario no exime a los estados de
hacer todo lo posible e implementar todo
tipo de programas y medidas para
garantizar el derecho a la salud y el
acceso efectivo a servicios de salud
ahora en ese trabajo que ustedes
realizaron con los pobladores cuáles son
los relatos constantes de su gente de
que han sido ustedes testigos
bueno las las personas hablan del
sufrimiento hablan de la muerte de la
desaparición de sus seres queridos
hablan del desplazamiento del miedo pero
también nos hablan de sus resistencias
de cómo las organizaciones se
organizaron para sobrevivir en el marco
del conflicto y también nos hablan del
presente de de la violencia que se
recicla y persiste en estos territorios
y exigen la plena implementación de los
acuerdos de paz y de programas y
políticas que permitan el pleno
desarrollo humano en estos territorios
nicolás el conflicto es igual en todas
las regiones donde ustedes han hecho
presencia
no definitivamente no
colombia es un país con uno de los
mayores índices de desigualdad en el
mundo
los territorios donde históricamente el
estado ha tenido menos presencia y donde
la pobreza y la marginalidad parece como
una condición estructural son los mismos
territorios donde la guerra se ha dado
con mayor intensidad y donde mayor se
ven los sus efectos de impactos así es
nicolás gracias por su tiempo por estar
aquí con nosotros en francés 24 nuestro
espacio de cinco minutos era nicolás
dota a coordinador general de médicos
del mundo ustedes gracias con tu bien
con nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias
[Música]